so between Avengers Game of Thrones and
now Star Wars how much of your lives are
spent keeping secrets Oh what of it all
of it dog nose you are so bottled up
with just the secrets of your work that
it's maddening you know it keeps the
kids in shoes so keep a mouth shut
that's very easy to keep your mouth shut
if you think you gonna lose your job
right that's very truth yeah I'm just
incredibly last night with such a relief
because I'm finding like oh my god
someone else knows okay good yes okay
yeah right yeah be like that yes uh with
this movie especially this character
with Han Solo so many people had said
you know it's an untouchable story why
are you doing this to my childhood why
would anyone especially all they want to
get him involved in something like this
like is the payoff for you guys after
last night's seeing it like is it it has
to be fantastic once you realize that
yes it worked I've got some friends who
super Star Wars geeks yeah who were
there last night and we're just like it
is it is my favorite ryan adams
songwriter who is crazy Star Wars nerd
an aficionado was just like it is it's
perfect it's it's the fans are gonna
love it it's perfect
and I think it puts about any fears
anybody had about whether Alden can do
it Alden is such a great actor he it is
really hard to walk away with the Coen
Brothers movie and he walked away with
that but he's such but he's a fabulous
actor and he's brilliant as as hard
we've all tried to talk bookie at some
point in our lives yeah little like I
could do like a baby work yeah okay I
can't do we say we gussto I just care
it's like if it's a for wifu jebecca go
to you by ultrasound right that's what
the sound is well both of you are either
of you be getting up super early on the
weekend to watch the real wedding
oh my entire village will it will yeah
hi guys I'm gonna screen Star Wars like
maybe you guys could know we're watching
the wedding though I'm really sorry
we've got a party there's bunting that
strange medieval procession taxpayers
are gonna pay four million dollars I
want to see what the Queen was we all do
I'm predicting Primrose yellow thank you